[Música]
hablamos de salud de nuestro programa
mañanero de france 24 directo américa
más o menos a la con nosotros en el
estudio mar vamos empezar hablando de la
genética y el coi 19 por la publicación
de nuevo estudio que pudiera explicar el
cubit grave no así de raúl muy buenos
días efectivamente estamos hablando de
un estudio que puede ayudar a
identificar esas causas genéticas del
coi grave sobre todo en esas personas
que no tienen factores de riesgo como
habilidades que de otra forma explicaría
en eso no por ejemplo pues la edad para
poner un ejemplo este estudio está
publicado en cell systems y lo que ha
identificado son
1300 a 70 genes que podrían estar
relacionados como decíamos con la
posibilidad de desarrollar un cuadro
grave severo de la enfermedad recordemos
los genes son esa unidad de información
genética que desarrollan una proteína
esa proteína codificada pues
características de nuestros cuerpos
desde los colores de los ojos hasta cómo
funcionan las células en este caso estos
son más de mil genes lo que hacen es
desarrollar 19 tipos de células están
relacionados con 19 tipos de células qué
un rol muy importante en combatir la
infección ahora profundizaremos en esto
por último también los autores del
estudio un dato importante concluyen que
estos mil trescientos setenta genes
podrían estar representar
aproximadamente el 77 por ciento de
todas estas características genéticas
que están relacionadas con el cónclave
seguimos hablando de células madre
producto cuáles son entonces las que
están afectadas por estos riesgos
genéticos de lo que estamos hablando
pues son básicamente dos dos tipos de
células y todas están relacionadas con
la respuesta inmune del cuerpo ante la
infección del virus que en este caso
provoca el commit 19 por un lado estamos
hablando de las células nk que es una
abreviación del inglés de natural
killers asesinas naturales y que pues
por su nombre ya nos dan una indicación
de su agresividad y su efectividad
también básicamente estas células que
son un tipo de linfocito de un glóbulo
blanco lo que hacen es atacar las
células que detectan que tienen algún
error ya sea porque están infectadas o
porque son tumorales también tienen
juegan un papel importante contra el
cáncer y lo hacen sin necesidad de un
aprendizaje previo por eso es que se les
dice que son linfocitos innatos por otro
lado las células te hemos hablado de
ellas también largamente en este
programa también son una función del
sistema inmune o una parte perdón del
sistema inmune estas si tienen
aprendizaje no tienen una memoria
después de una infección o de una vacuna
son las que reaccionan y pues en estos
casos el mal funcionamiento un mal
desarrollo de estas células es explicado
desde la genética es lo que podría
provocar que las personas tengan una
enfermedad más grave cuando se infectan
marc este es el único estudio que habla
de esta relación entre genética y el
club y 19 o tenemos otros tenemos muchos
de hecho desde el inicio de la pandemia
ha habido mucho interés por
entender esa relación entre la genética
y esta enfermedad y especialmente como
decíamos para comprender por qué
personas que aparentemente podían ser
sanas o que no tienen otros factores de
riesgo pues han llegado a enfermarse de
maneras muy graves no hay un consenso
general todavía al menos en lo concreto
pero sí hemos visto que en general lo
que hay en los estudios es que estos
cambios genéticos de estas zonas de
nuestros genomas que están relacionadas
con el kobe grave tienen que ver 1 con
el sistema inmune como estábamos
explicando a otro también con genes
relacionados con otras enfermedades de
pulmón es es decir pues que podrían
señalar un mal funcionamiento del órgano
o una excesiva inflamación que también
es uno de los de los factores que
explica un kobe grave otra cosa también
tienen que ver con la coagulación de la
sangre y con las plaquetas aunque
todavía se está por ver exactamente qué
relación tiene y por último también pues
con los llamados interferón es de esa
forma de las primeras cosas que se
identificó cuando se estudió la genética
y el cobertizo una vez que son unas
proteínas que sirven como señalización
como unas banderas que avisan al sistema
inmune de que hay unas células que deben
ser combatidas o algún patógeno virus
bacteria son al sólo algunos ejemplos
cada vez hay más estudios y hará falta
ver pues seguirlos como siempre de cerca
para saber cómo avanza pero sin duda
alguna cada vez que hablamos de estos
temas más me impresiona la perfección y
cómo funciona nuestro cuerpo no en
cuestión de pues combatir virus la
memoria de las células es como un reloj
impresionante marc a futuro qué
implicaciones pueden tener estos
hallazgos estos estudios pues yo primero
quisiera romper a favor del conocimiento
por el conocimiento si no se ha entender
todas estas cosas es muy interesante
también para saber cómo reacciona
nuestro cuerpo como decías ahora mismo
las enfermedades a las infecciones y más
de una infección nueva como es el commit
19 relativamente nueva ahora no pero es
verdad que también podría tener
aplicaciones útiles sobre todo en
términos de terapia no hay un ejemplo
que ya tenemos que son estos
interferones estas banderas del sistema
inmune que estábamos hablando que pues
son unas proteínas que de hecho también
se pueden crear en el laboratorio que ya
se usan en otras terapias por ejemplo
contra la hepatitis y que se han
estudiado qué efectos tienen contra el
commit 19no esta terapia con estos
interferones y por último también
queríamos explicar que hay la gran
pregunta para saber si esto puede ayudar
a predecir quién tiene pues una
predisposición genética a sufrir cobit
grave o no y pues toca decir que el
problema es que todavía no hay tanto
consenso no hay tanta especificidad en
esos genes y podría ser pues que
haciendo un escaneo de estas zonas
susceptibles a tener que ver con el coi
grave dejáramos por fuera muchas otras
cosas que todavía no conocemos y se pre
dijera por ejemplo riesgo o que no hay
riesgo cuando en realidad si recordemos
que estos estudios el primer estudio que
mencionábamos el 77 por ciento sólo es
decir que faltaría como un cuarto
todavía de genes por identificar que
puedan tener a ver con el commit grave
entonces pues raúl como siempre
estaremos pendientes de cómo avanza todo
así es mar mientras tanto que la ciencia
vaya avanzando y vaya evolucionando el
trabajo los científicos de verdad pues
impecable y tenemos mucho que
agradecerles a ellos muchas gracias voy
a indicar lo fácil es animar también
gracias a ti como siempre por toda la
información de salud pasamos a saludar a
nuestro segundo invitado al día